I want to bring this part of the class
to an end so this is our last lecture
but for our series of guest lectures and
in this talk I hope to address some of
the state of deep learning today and
kind of bring up some of the limitations
of the algorithms that you've been
seeing in this class so far so we got a
really good taste of some of the
limitations specifically in
reinforcement learning algorithms that
Lex gave in the last lecture and that's
really going to build on or I'm gonna
use that to build on top of during this
lecture and just to end on I'm gonna
bring you I'm gonna introduce you to
some new frontiers in deep learning that
are really really inspiring it and at
the cutting edge of research today
before we do that I'd like to just make
some administrative announcements so
t-shirts have arrived and we'll be
distributing them today and we'd like to
distribute first to the registered for
credit students after that we will be
happy to distribute to registered
listeners and then after that if there's
any remaining we'll give out to
listeners if they'd want if they're
interested so for those of you who are
taking this class for credit I need to
reiterate what kind of options you have
to actually fulfill your credit
requirement so the first option is a
group project proposal presentation so
for this option you'll be given the
opportunity to pitch a novel deep
learning idea to a panel of judges on
Friday you'll have exactly one minute to
make your pitch as clear error as clear
and as concisely as possible so this is
really difficult to do in one minute and
this kind of one of the challenges that
were we're putting on you in addition to
actually coming up with the deep
learning idea itself if you want to go
down this route for your final project
then you'll need to submit your teams
which have to be of size three or four
by the end of today so at 9:00 p.m.
today we'd like those in you'll have to
do teams of three or four so if you want
a group working in groups of one or two
then you'll have to you're you're
welcome to do that but you won't be able
to actually submit your final project as
part of a presentation on Friday you can
submit it to us and we'll we'll give you
the grade for the class
like that so groups are due 9:00 p.m.
today and you have to submit your slides
by 9:00 p.m. tomorrow presentations are
at class on Friday in this room if you
don't want to do a project for
presentation you have a second option
which is to write a one-page paper
review of a deep learning idea so any
idea or any paper that you find
interesting is is welcome here so we
really accept anything and we're really
free in this in this option as well I
want to highlight some of the exciting
new talks that we have coming up after
today so tomorrow will have two sets of
guest lectures first we'll hear from
aura's Muller who is the chief architect
of nvidia x' self-driving car team so
hers and his team were actually known
for some really exciting work that abu
is showing yesterday during her lecture
and they're known for this development
of an end-to-end platform for autonomous
driving that takes directly image data
and produces a steering control command
at the car for the car at the output
then we'll hear about we'll hear from
two Google brain researchers on recent
advancements on image classification at
Google and also we'll hear about some
super recent advancements and additions
to the tensorflow pipeline that were
actually just released a couple days ago
so this is really really new stuff
tomorrow afternoon we'll get together
for one of the most exciting parts of
this class so what will happen is we'll
have each of the sponsors actually come
up to the front of the class here we
have four sponsors that will present on
each of these four boards and you'll be
given the opportunity to basically
connect with each of them through the
through the ways of a recruitment booth
and basically they're going to be
looking at students that might be
interested in deep learning internships
or employment opportunities so this is
really an incredible opportunity for you
guys to connect with these companies in
a very very very direct manner so we
highly recommend that you take advantage
of that there will be info sessions with
pizza provided on Thursday with one of
these guest lectures with one of these
industry companies and we'll be sending
out more details with that today as well
so on Friday we'll continue with the
guest lectures and hear from Lisa and
meanie who is the head of IBM Research
in Cambridge she's actually also the
director of the MIT IBM lab and this is
a lab that was just founded a couple or
actually about a month ago or two months
ago
we'll be hearing about how IBM is
creating AI systems that are capable of
not only deep learning but going a step
past deep learning they're capable of or
trying to be capable of learning and
recently on a higher-order sense and
then finally we'll hear from a principal
researcher at $0.10 AI lab about
combining computer vision and social
networks it's a very interesting topic
that we haven't really touched upon in
this class this topic of social networks
and using massive big data collected
from from humans themselves and then as
I mentioned before in the afternoon
we'll go through and hear about the
final project presentations we'll
celebrate with some pizza and the awards
that will be given out to the top
projects during those during that
session as well so now let's start with
the technical content for this class I'd
like to start by just kind of over
viewing the type of architectures that
we've talked about so far for the most
part these architectures can be thought
of almost pattern-recognition
architectures so they take as input data
and the whole point of their pipeline
their internals are performing feature
extraction and and what they're really
doing is taking all the sensory data
trying to figure out what are the
important pieces what are the patterns
to be learned within the data such that
they can produce a decision at the
output we've seen this take many forms
so the decision could be a prediction it
could be a detection or even an action
like an agree enforcement learning
setting we've even learned how these
models can be viewed in a generative
sense to go in the opposite direction it
actually generate new synthetic data but
in general we've been dealing with
algorithms that are really optimized to
do well and only a single task but they
really fail to think like humans do
especially when we consider a higher
order level of an
telogen Slyke I defined on the first day
to understand this in a lot more detail
we have to go back to this very famous
theorem that was dating back almost 30
years from today this theorem which is
known as the universal approximation
theorem was one of the most impactful
theorems and neural networks when it
first came out because it had such a
profound it proved such a profound claim
what it states is that a neural network
with a single hidden layer is sufficient
to approximate any function to any
arbitrary level of accuracy now in this
class we deal with networks that are
deep they're not single layered so
they're actually more than a single
layer so actually they contain even more
complexity than the network down
referring to here but this theorem
proves that we actually only need one
layer to accomplish or to approximate
any function in the world and if you
believe that any problem can actually be
reduced to a sets of inputs and outputs
in this form of a function then this
theorem shows you that it's that a
neural network with just a single layer
is able to solve any problem in the
world now this is an incredibly powerful
result but if you look closely there are
a few very important caveats I'm not
actually telling you how large that
hidden layer has to be to accomplish
this task
now with the size of your problem the
hidden layer and the number of units in
that hidden layer may be exponentially
large and they'll grow exponentially
with the difficulty of your problem
this makes training that network very
difficult so I never actually told you
anything about how to obtain that
Network I just told you that it existed
and there is a possible network in the
realm of all neural networks that could
solve that problem but as we know in
practice actually training neural
networks because of their non convex
structure is extremely difficult so this
theorem is really a perfect example of
the possible effects of overhyping in AI
so over the history of AI we've had two
AI winters and this theorem was one of
the resurgence
after the first day I winter but it also
caused a huge false hype in the power of
these neural networks which ultimately
led to yet another AI winter and I feel
like as a class it's very important to
bring this up because right now we're
very much in the state of a huge amount
of overhyping in deep learning
algorithms so these algorithms are
especially in the media being portrayed
that they can accomplish human level
intelligence and human level reasoning
and simply this is not true so I think
such over hype is extremely dangerous
and resulted well we know it resulted in
in both of the two past AI winters and I
think as a class it's very important for
us to focus on some of the limitations
of these algorithms so that we don't
overhyped them but we provide realistic
guarantees or realistic expectations
rather on what these algorithms can
accomplish and finally going past these
limitations the last part of this talk
will actually focus on some of the
exciting research like I mentioned
before that tries to take a couple of
these limitations and really focus on
possible solutions and possible ways
that we can move past them okay so let's
start and I think one of the best
examples of a potential danger of neural
networks comes from this paper from
google deepmind named understanding deep
neural networks requires rethinking
generalization and generalization was
this topic that we discussed in the
first lecture so this is the notion of a
gap or a difference between your
training accuracy and your test accuracy
if you're able to achieve equal training
and test accuracy that means you have
essentially no generalization gap you're
able to generalize perfectly to to your
test dataset but if there's a huge
disparity between these two datasets and
your model is performing much better on
your training data set than your test
dataset this means that you're not able
to actually generalize to brand new
images you're only just memorizing the
training examples
and what this paper did was they
performed the following experiment so
they took images from imagenet so you
can here see four examples of these
images here and what they did was they
rolled a case I did die where K is the
number of all possible labels in that
data set and this allowed them to
randomly assign brand new labels to each
of these images so what used to be a dog
they call now a banana and what they
used to be that banana is now called the
dog and what it used to be called that
second dog is now a tree so note that
the two dogs have actually been
transformed into two separate things so
things that used to be in the same class
are now in completely disjoint classes
and things that were in disjoint classes
maybe now in the same class so basically
we're completely randomizing our labels
entirely and what they did was they
tried to see if a neural network could
still learn random labels and here's
what they found so as you'd expect when
they tested this neural network with
random labels as they increase the
randomness on the x axis so going from
left to right this is the original
labels before randomizing anything and
then they started randomizing their test
accuracy gradually decreased and this is
as expected because we're trying to
learn something that has absolutely no
pattern in it but then what's really
interesting is that then they looked at
the training accuracy and what they
found was that the neural network was
able to with 100% accuracy get the
training set correct every single time
no matter how many random labels they
introduced the training set would always
be shattered or in other words every
single example in the training set could
be perfectly classified so this means
that modern deep neural networks
actually have the capacity to
brute-force memorize massive data sets
even on the size of imagenet with
completely random labels they're able to
memorize every single example in that
data set and this is a very powerful
result is it drives home this point that
neural networks are you
really excellent function approximator
x' so this also connects back to the
universal approximation theorem that I
talked about before but they're really
good approximator is for just a single
function like I said which means that we
can always create this maximum
likelihood estimate of our data using a
neural network such that if we were
given a new data point like this purple
one on the bottom it's easy for us to
compute its estimate probability or its
estimate output just by intercepting it
with that maximum likelihood estimate
but if that's only if I'm looking at a
place that we have sufficient training
data already what if I extend these x
axes and look at what the neural network
predicts beyond that in these locations
these are actually the locations that we
care about most right these are the edge
cases and driving these are the cases
that we don't have met many or a lot of
data that was collected and these are
usually the cases where safety critical
applications are like our most important
right so we need to be able to make sure
when we sample the neural network from
these locations are we able to know that
the neural network are we able to get
feedback from the neural network that it
actually doesn't know what it's talking
about so this notion leads nicely into
the idea of what is known as advertised
adversarial attacks where I can give you
directly and give and neural network to
images like on the left like this one
and on the right an adversarial image
that to a human look exactly the same
but to the networks they're incorrectly
classified 100% of the time so the image
on the right shows an example of a
temple which when I feed to a neural
network it gives me back label of a
temple but when I apply some adversarial
noise it classifies this image
incorrectly as an ostrich so for this
I'd like to focus on this piece
specifically so to understand the
limitations of neural networks the first
thing we have to do is actually
understand how we can break them and
this perturb noise is actually very
intelligently designed so this is not
just random noise but we're actually
modifying pics
in specific locations to maximally
change or mess up our output prediction
so we want to modify the pixels in such
a way that we're decreasing our accuracy
as much as possible and if you remember
back to how we actually trained our
neural networks this might sound very
similar so if you remember training and
neural network is simply optimizing over
our weights theta so to do this we
simply compute the gradient of theta
with respect to our loss function with
respect to theta and we simply perturb
our weights in the direction that will
minimize our loss now also remember that
when we do this we're perturbing theta
but we're fixing our X and our Y this is
our training label our training data and
our training labels now for adversarial
examples
we're just shuffling the variables a
little bit so now we want to optimize
over the image itself not the weight so
we fix the weights and the target label
itself and we optimize over the image X
we want to make small changes to that
image X such that we increase our loss
as much as possible and we want to go in
the opposite direction of training now
and these are just some of the
limitations of neural networks and for
the remainder of this class I want to
focus on some of the really really
exciting new frontiers of deep learning
that focus on just two of these
specifically I want to focus on the
notion of understanding uncertainty and
deep neural networks and understanding
when our model doesn't know what it was
trained to know maybe because it wasn't
it didn't receive enough training data
to support that hypothesis and
furthermore I wanted to focus on this
notion of learning how to learn models
because optimization of neural networks
is extremely difficult it's extremely
limited in its current nature because
they're optimized just to do a single
task so what we really want to do is
create neural networks that are capable
of performing not one task but a set of
sequences of tasks that are maybe
dependent in some fashion so let's start
with this notion of uncertainty in deep
neural networks and to do that
I'd like to introduce this field called
Bayesian deep learning
now to understand Bayesian deep learning
let's first understand why we even care
about uncertainty so this should be
pretty obvious but suppose we were given
a network that was trained to
distinguish between cats and dogs that
input were given a lot of tests
imitating images of cats and dogs and
it's simply at the output we're
producing an output probability of being
a cat or a dog now this model is trained
on either on only cats or dogs so if I
showed another cat it should be very
confident in its output well let's
suppose I give it a horse and I force
that network because it's the same
network to produce an output of being a
probability of a cat or a probability of
a dog now we know that these
probabilities have to add up to 1
because that's actually the definition
that we constrain our network to follow
so that means by definition one of these
categories so the network has to produce
one of these categories so the notion of
probability and the notion of
uncertainty are actually very different
but a lot of deep learning practitioners
often mix these two ideas so uncertainty
is not probability neural networks are
detect or trained to detect or produce
probabilities at their output at their
output but they're not trained to
produce uncertainty values so if we put
this horse into the same network we'll
get a set of uncertainty bility values
that add up to 1 but what we really want
to see is we want to see a very low
uncertainty in that a very low certainty
in that prediction and one possible way
to accomplish this in deep learning is
through the eyes of Bayesian deep
learning and to understand this let's
briefly start by formulating our problem
again so first let's go through like the
variables right so we want to
approximate this variable Y or output Y
given some raw data X and really what we
mean by training is we want to find this
functional mapping F parameterize by our
weights theta such that we minimize the
loss between our predict examples and
our true outputs y so Bayesian neural
networks take it
different approach to solve this problem
they aim to learn a posterior over our
weights given the data so they attempt
to say what is the probability that I
see this model with these weights given
the data in my training set
now it's called Bayesian deep learning
because we can simply rewrite this
posterior using Bayes rule however in
practice it's rarely possible to
actually compute this compute this Bayes
rule update and it just turns out to be
intractable so instead we have to find
out ways to actually approximate it
through sampling so one way that I'll
talk about today is a very simple notion
that we've actually already seen in the
first lecture and it goes back to this
idea of using dropout so if you remember
what dropout was dropout is this notion
of randomly killing off a certain
percentage of neurons in each of the
hidden layers now I'm going to tell you
not how to use it as a regularizer
but how to use dropout as a way to
produce reliable uncertainty measures
for your neural network so to do this we
have to think of capital T stochastic
passes through our network where each
stochastic pass performs one iteration
of dropouts
each time you iterate dropout you're
basically just applying a Bernoulli mask
of ones and zeros over each of your
weights so going from the left to the
right you can see our weights which is
like this matrix here different colors
represent the intensity of that weight
and we element-wise multiply those
weights by our Bernoulli mask width
which is just either a 1 or a 0 in every
location the output is a new set of
weights with certain of those dropped
out with certain aspects of those
dropped out now all we have to do is
compute this T times capital T times we
get Kappa theta T weights and we use
those theta T different models to
actually produce an empirical average of
our output class given the data so
that's this guy
well we're actually really interested in
why I brought this topic up was the
notion of uncertainty though and that's
the variance of our predictions right
there so this is a very powerful idea
all it means is that we can obtain
reliable model uncertainty estimates
simply by training our network during
runtime with dropout and then instead of
estimating or classifying just a single
pass through this network at test time
we classify capital teet iterations of
this network and then use it to compute
a variance over these outputs and that
variance gives us a estimation of our
uncertainty now to give you an example
of how this looks in practice let's look
at this this network that was trained to
take as input images of the real world
and outputs predicted depth maps oh it
looks like my text was a little off but
that's okay so at the output we have a
predicted death map where at each pixel
the network is predicting the depth in
the real world of that pixel now when we
run Bayesian model uncertainty using the
exact same dropout method that I just
described we can see that the end the
model is most uncertain in some very
interesting locations so first of all
pay attention to that location right
there if you look where where is that
location exactly it's just the window
sill of this car and in computer vision
windows and specular objects are very
difficult to to basically model because
we can't actually tell their surface
reliably right so we're seeing the light
from actually the sky we're not actually
seeing the surface of the window in that
location so it can be very difficult for
us to model the the depth in that place
additionally we see that the model is
very uncertain on the edges of the cars
because these are places where the depth
is changing very rapidly so the
prediction may be least accurate in
these locations so having reliable
uncertainty estimates can be an
extremely powerful
way to actually interpret deep learning
models and also provide human
practitioners especially in the realm of
safe AI that's a way to interpret the
results and also trusts our results with
a certain amount of or a certain grain
of salt so for the next and final part
of this talk I'd like to address this
notion of learning to learn so this is a
really cool sounding topic it aims to
basically learn not just a single model
that's optimized to perform a single
task like we've learned basically and
all of our lectures previous to this one
but it learns how to learn which model
to use to train that task so first let's
understand like why we might want to do
something like that I hope this is
pretty obvious to you by now but humans
are not built in a way where we're
learning where we're executing just a
single task at a time we're executing
many many many different tasks and all
of these tasks are constantly
interacting with each other in ways that
learning one task can actually aid
speed-up or deter the learning of
another task at any given time modern
deep neural network architectures are
not like this they're optimized for a
single task and this goes back to the
very beginning of this talk where we
talked about the universal approximator
and as these models become more and more
complex what ends up happening is that
you have to have more and more expert
knowledge to actually build and deploy
these models in practice and that's
exactly why all of you are here you're
here to basically get that experience
such that you yourselves can build these
deep learning models so what we want is
actually an automated machine learning
framework where we can actually learn to
learn and this basically means we want
to build the model that learns which
model to use given a problem definition
one example that I'd like to just use as
an illustration of this idea so there
are many ways that auto ml can be
accomplished and this is just one
example of those ways so I'd like to
focus on this
illustration here and I like to walk
through it it's just a way that we can
learn to learn so this this system
focuses on two parts the first part is
the controller RNN in red on the left
and this controller RNN is basically
just sampling different architectures of
neural networks so if you remember in
your first lab you created an RNN that
could sample different music notes this
is no different except now we're not
sampling music notes we're sampling an
entire neural network itself so we're
sampling that parameters that define
that neural network so let's call that
the architecture or the child's network
so that's the network that will actually
be used to solve our task in the end so
that network is passed on to the second
bottle so that network is passed on to
the second one
and in that piece we actually use that
network that was generated by the Arnon
to train a model depending on how well
that model did we can provide feedback
to the RNN such I can produce an even
better model on the next time step so
let's go into this piece by piece so
let's look at just the RNN part in more
detail so this is the RNN or the
architecture generator so like I said
this is very similar to the way that you
are generating songs in your first lab
except now we're not generating songs
the time steps are going from layers on
the x-axis and we're just generating
parameters or
hyper parameters rather for each of
those layers so this is a generator for
a convolutional neural network because
we're producing parameters like the
filter height the filter width the
stride height etc so what we can do is
we can add each time step produce a
probability distribution of over each of
these parameters and we can essentially
just sample an architecture or sample a
child Network once we have that child
Network which I'm showing right here in
blue we can train it using our data set
that we ultimately want to solve so we
put our training data in and we get our
predicted labels out this is the this is
the realm that we've been dealing with
so far in this
right so we have our this is basically
what we've seen so far so this is just a
single network and we have our training
data that we're using to Train it we see
how well this does depending on the
accuracy of this model that accuracy is
used to provide feedback back to the RNN
and update how it produces or how it
generates these models so let's look at
this one more time to summarize this is
an extremely powerful idea it's really
really really exciting because it shows
that an RNN can be actually combined in
a reinforcement learning paradigm where
the R and n itself is almost like the
agent in reinforcement learning it's
learning to make changes to the child
network architecture depending on how
that child network performs on a
training set this means that we're able
to create an AI system capable of
generating brand-new neural networks
specialized to solve specific tasks
rather than just creating a single
neural network that we create just to
solve that tasks that we want to create
that we want to solve
thus this has significantly reduced the
difficulty in optimizing these neural
networks for architectures for different
tasks and this also reduces the need for
expert engineers to design these
architectures so this really gets at the
heart of artificial intelligence so when
I began this course we spoke about what
it actually means to be intelligent and
loosely I defined this as the ability to
take information process that
information and use it to inform future
decisions so the human learning pipeline
is not restricted to solving just one
task at a time like I mentioned before
how we learn one task can greatly impact
speed up or even slow down our learning
of other tasks and the artificial models
that we create today simply do not
capture this phenomenon to reach
artificial general intelligence we need
to actually build AI that can not only
learn a single task but also be able to
improve its own learning and reasoning
such that it can generalize two sets of
related
dependent tasks I'll leave this with you
as a thought-provoking point and
encourage you to to all talk to each
other on some ways that we can reach
this this higher-order level of
intelligence that's not just pattern
recognition but rather a higher-order
form of reasoning and actually thinking
about about the problems that we're
trying to solve thank you
[Applause]